Speaker 1: All right, let's look at something
very, very interesting. Yesterday, I played
for you, we did kind of like a review of weekend
disinformation and propaganda about vaccines and
COVID yesterday. And one of the clips I played
for you was a clip of Republican Congresswoman
Nancy Mace saying on Fox News, Hey, you know
what? Natural immunity is better than getting
vaccinated. So maybe it's a good thing if more
people just get this new Omicron variant. And
that was a clip we played yesterday. And what's
fascinating is within hours of that appearance,
she was on CNN saying, I'm vaccinated. Vaccines
are great and everybody should get vaccinated.
And it is an incredible Trumpian move
of, say everything about any issue
so that whoever can find an instance of you saying
the thing that they want to hear you say, speaking
out of both sides of her mouth. So let's review.
Here's her clip on Fox News over the weekend.
Take a look that we played this yesterday,
Speaker 3: as in one of the things that the
CDC has not done and no, no policymaker
at the federal level has done so far is
taken into account what natural immunity does, and
that may be what we're seeing in Florida today.
And some studies that I've read natural immunity
gives you twenty seven times more protection
against future COVID infection than vaccination.
And so when you take all of the science into
account and not selectively choosing what science
to follow when we are making policy decisions and
you're seeing, I believe Governor DeSantis is,
you know, seeing the fruit of that labor today.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Ron DeSantis is doing a great
job. One of the worst governors when it came to
handling COVID natural immunity gives you 27 times
the protection it doesn't. Maybe she meant 27
percent in one case if you were recently infected
versus having a vaccine tailored to earlier,
earlier variants. But of course, solving COVID
building immunity by letting everyone get sick is
a way to have millions and millions of people die
right where we've had hundreds of thousands die,
which is crazy, but we would have millions
and millions dead. Horribly irresponsible
comment to make. What on earth is she talking
about? But then she goes on CNN, and she says
something totally different. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: I've been a proponent of vaccinations
and wearing masks when we need to. I've run ads
encouraging my district to go and get vaccinated.
And when we have these variants and we have these
spikes, I take every precaution from washing our
hands to wearing the N95 or ninety five mask.
Speaker 1: Wow. Wow. This is the Trump idea.
Take every side of an issue so everyone
can find you saying something you like.
And she's, of course, tailoring it to
the audience. One message for CNN viewers
and a different message for Fox News viewers.
It's quite frankly like two totally different
people. I mean, it sounds like two different
people. She has to tell the base she doesn't
like the vaccines. She's skeptical. What
about freedom? What about just letting natural
immunity give us protection? But then she has to
go to the more moderate audience on CNN and say,
I've been for vaccines from the beginning.
I've been for masks, wear an N95 going above
and beyond, and she can maintain the kind of
plausible deniability that may suit her by taking
a different position for each group. This is
part of the Republican assault on reality.
What should we be doing? Because at the end
of the day, we can explain why she's doing
this by saying, Well, look at the audience
on Fox and then look at the audience on CNN.
But ultimately, these are conflicting
statements saying we should be looking
very strongly at guilt, getting natural immunity
by getting people sick and having them recover.
If people get vaccinated, your chance of
getting sick is lower. If you wear a mask,
your chance of getting sick is lower, so they're
not. You can't do both. They are opposites,
quite literally. There's a really good quote from
the French philosopher Jean-Paul Sartre, who he
he made this statement about anti-Semites.
But if you replace anti-Semite with Trump
cultist or whatever it applies to what is going on
right now, let's look at the quote. So, he wrote,
Never believe that anti-Semites will say never
believe that Trumpists are completely unaware of
the absurdity of their replies. They know that
their remarks are frivolous, open to challenge,
but they are amusing themselves, for it is their
adversary who is obliged to use words responsibly,
since he believes in words, the anti-Semites, the
Trumpists have the right to play. They even like
to play with discourse for by giving ridiculous
reasons. They discredit the seriousness of their
interlocutors. They delight in acting in bad
faith, since they seek not to persuade by sound
argument, but to intimidate and to dis concert.
If you press the. Too closely. They will abruptly
fall silent, loftily indicating by some phrase
that the time for argument is passed, and that's
exactly what they will do. They will say something
like, Well, I'm not going to split hairs with you.
I'm not. Well, this isn't about point
counterpoint, et cetera, et cetera. Beautifully,
accurately applies to what we are seeing right
now. That was a phrase. And to be clear, because
I know that then other YouTube channels will
say, look at David Pakman saying Trumpists are
like anti-Semites. I'm not saying Trumpists are
anti-Semites, although some are. What I'm saying
is the mechanism described by Jean-Paul Sartre
there, which he talked about with anti-Semites,
applies today with how these Trump cultists play
fast and loose with what we would call the truth.